how do you feel about the way sport your
sport boxing is going right now with all
the uh
you know instagram versions of it i know
you love these guys youtube yeah the
youtube fights and the jake paul
suddenly is
having heavy weight or lightweight
whatever it is and this is the deal we
took talking from a business perspective
i don't care if it looks goofy or funny
that money's real and these guys are
getting knocked out this is an
entertainment you know listen
i bring the world champion i put them on
my card right
let's say he's the great world champion
right now right uh-huh
and i'm giving him some points say um he
came he brings a million people that's a
lot i'm giving them up upside right
mm-hmm
this little [ __ ] blonde hair
blue-eyed [ __ ] coming up with 70 million
right yeah so you know what i mean it's
like the numbers game purely no no no
listen you have to listen to this [ __ ]
these 70 million people never saw a
boxing match before right yeah and they
coming for this little [ __ ] i love him
yes i play with my card he's beautiful
he's beautiful so from the business
perspective you like it yeah but from
the pure i mean look i look at you and i
think this is a guy who took the sport
and the science and the the the
philosophy of boxing for you didn't do
it for money
you did it because you had the passion
then you went through the olympics and
always thing does it
does it cheapen your sport or no no
that's all i'm trying to do is what
gives guys our age upset because
changing of the guard is hard to
understand a heart i want to understand
and that's just what it is it's the
changing of the guards and these um
tick-tock guys are part of it yeah
you understand that all right that's
also getting into it it's also giving me
more yeah let's get more exposure
i don't know what you're saying just
double that today i get it but imagine
it 10 years from now
i want to have the
what do you call them again
youtube stars i want to have other
youtube boxers
have a tournament to fight who will be
the champion of the world in that world
and just keep it in that category
but the crossover was so fast that's
what do they have another belt it'll be
whatever boat they want to be and then
they put that up against the boxes but
it's all hype yeah hype cell fights
fights don't sell fights hype cell
fights yeah but the fact that i have a
conversation with people of saying like
oh it's pre-discussed how it's gonna go
it's gonna be arranged and all this
stuff even though it's a conversation
because i could tell you when you got in
the ring there was no conversation about
whether or not this guy's going to take
a fall or he's not going to hit him in
the head
like them hey how you feeling are you
all right well i said what about me i
was fighting too yeah i didn't have
somebody in the way am i all right
that's rep bro yeah your rep precedes
you sorry
[Music]